Демонстранти у Берліні мітингують на велосипедах.
Вони хочуть ще більше велосипедних маршрутів у центрі міста,
ще більше пішохідних зон і, як наслідок, менше автомобілів у столиці.
Я думаю, що вже достатньо інфраструктури для моторизованого транспорту.
Нам потрібно зробити більше саме для велосипедистів.
Нам потрібно боротися за "зеленіший" Берлін.
Тим часом машини не можуть проїхати - вони змушені
поступитися велосипедистам. Як до них ставляться водії?
Я думаю, що і для одних,і для інших має бути місце.
Не тільки для велосипедистів чи водіїв. Усі важливі.
А як щодо квадроцикла чи веломобіля?
Велоспорт в усіх його формах став дуже популярним у столиці Німеччини.
Середня швидкість у місті - 25 кілометрів на годину, а загалом - 30.
Цього разу протестувальників пустили на міську автостраду.
Поліція стримує машини. Останніми роками уряд Берліна
ухвалив нову транспортну політику, збільшивши кількість велодоріжок
та перетворивши деякі вулиці на велосипедні та пішохідні зони.
Але дехто прагне ще радикальнішого підходу.
Ми виступаємо з ініціативою "Берлін без автомобілів",
тому що зазвичай вулиці виглядають не так, як тут.
Вони просто забиті машинами. І ми думаємо, що це несправедливо,
особливо в центрі міст. Багато людей більше не користуються автомобілями,
а вони займають так багато місця. Машини - це вже пережиток минулого.
У багатьох частинах світу центр міста швидко трансформується.
Ми поспілкувалися з архітектором, який добре знається на цих викликах.
Я думаю, що пандемія служить для пришвидшення процесу,
який тривав давно. Просто прогуляйтеся нашими пішохідними зонами,
і ви побачите проблеми.
Люди нині роблять більше покупок онлайн.
Великі торгові центри особливо постраждали останніми роками,
а пандемія ще більше погіршила ситуацію.
Багато торгових площ та автостоянок нині стоять порожніми.
Цей колишній універмаг у центрі західнонімецького міста був трансформований
під житловий будинок з магазинами. Нині машина тут нікому не потрібна.
Важливо забезпечити як проживання, так і роботу в місті.
Тільки так можна зменшити обсяг приміських перевезень.
Цю будівлю в центральному берлінському районі Мітте
також спроєктували саме для людей без машин.
Тут магазини, студії художників, квартири, а також офіси.
Усе це призначено для проживання та роботи під одним дахом.
Перехожі можуть зазирнути всередину.
Це дозволяє і вам знати, що відбувається ззовні,
хто проходить повз, і я отримую насолоду від рослин, які тут ростуть.
Немає сумніву, що центр міста з меншою кількістю автівок приємніший.
Столиця Данії Копенгаген заборонила всі автомобілі у центрі міста.
Париж планує висадити більше дерев на Єлисейських полях
і навколо Тріумфальної арки, намагаючись значно скоротити рух транспорту.
В Нью-Йорку ж деякі ділянки Бродвею біля Таймс-сквер вже без автомобілів,
натомість усіяні вуличними кафе, розробленими датськими архітекторами.
Виробники автомобілів також зрозуміли, що часи змінюються.
Фольксваген розробив автономні шатли, які мають стати таксі майбутнього
та допомогти скоротити міський рух.
Наш бренд трансформується з чистого виробника автомобілів
у свого роду постачальника засобів пересування.
Тому незалежно від того, купуєте ви у нас автомобіль, берете його в лізинг
чи орендуєте, незалежно від того, керуєте ви самі чи ні,
наша бізнес-модель працює в будь-якому випадку.
Тим часом, у Берліні демонстранти на велосипедах,
окупувавши міську автостраду, сподіваються, що колись німецькій столиці
більше не буде потрібна ця дорога -
принаймні для автомобілів.